[Musique]
dans le cadre de l'opération boîte
quartier qui consiste à replanter des
espèces endémiques de la réunion les
jeunes en service civique de l' académie
des dalons sont allés à la rencontre des
habitants de bois de nèfles saint paul
afin de savoir ce qu'ils aimeraient voir
planter dans leur quartier on vient voir
les gens voient poser des questions pour
savoir ce qu'est et même en vue même
veut bien ici à bois nef des pieds de
bois endémique et de voir leurs
souvenirs avant d'être fruitiers tisane
série est aussi beau à voir
pour adèle oddo conseillère
départementale il s'agit là d'une action
à double vocation
on est sur une action qui y amènent les
jeunes vers la rencontre de la
population et s'insérer socialement et
puissent investir dans une mission qui
demain matin peut les amener à
comprendre que pour le travail il faut
pouvoir aller vers les gens et
s'investir être dans l'action on a un
autre atout qui est cet engagement que
le département a pris sur le plan un
million d'arbres ou le choix des arbres
ne se fait pas sans la concertation de
la population donc vous aurez bien
compris qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes de
l'académie des dalons vont à la
rencontre des habitants de bois nef pour
comprendre et essayer d'étudier quels
étaient les espèces qui existe et que
les gens aimeraient revoir soit chez eux
soit au niveau de la ville soit au
niveau du quartier une initiative très
appréciée par la population
c'est important parce qu'on fait vivre
le quartier avec les gens du quartier
moi j'aimerais bien par exemple plus
rire les ronds points
fleury a devant les mairies les églises
fois que
pour que ça fasse jolie et les arbres
aussi parce qu'on a besoin d'être long
pour les oiseaux et tout ça mais c'est
vrai que les fleurs quand on arrive dans
un quartier où s'effleurer ont fait voir
c'est ça c'est celle et la beauté des
yeux avant tout l'opération bois de
quartier qui s'inscrit dans le plan un
million d'arbres du département se
poursuivra ce samedi 24 juillet sur la
place de l'église et le mercredi 28 à la
bibliothèque
l'action fera l'objet d'une restitution
partager avec les habitants
[Musique]